you've reached the voicemail of Dwight
Kurt Schrute please leave
[Music]
I have no feeling in my fingers or penis
but I think it was worth it
ah
um I was laying on the ground
defenseless and uh he just kept throwing
him
until he exhausted himself and uh
then
how about icing it LOL Dwight
yep yep yep
looking good
oh what a day what a day Dwight are you
carrying a gun The holster was a gift
from my great uncle honk um I don't know
I guess he's saying that he's proud of
me Dwight guns make me really
uncomfortable the gun is just an
accessory to the holster okay I can't
walk around wearing an empty holster why
do you need to wear the holster at all
why do you need to keep wearing those
booby shirts all the time thank you you
your cell phone in it instead
instead hello
you could put a banana in it why would I
put a banana in my holster in case you
weren't hungry now but you got hungry
later Dwight no gun okay don't make us
call Joe okay all right fine everyone
calm down
someone get me a banana sorry I freaked
you guys out
it's so loud
are you feeling better no
well you're the cutest button
worked up quite a sweat is removing all
of sprinkles organs right now and
sending them to the lab
I am a farmer Angela what does that mean
okay when a farmer sees an animal that
is in pain that has no quality of life
that has no utility a farmer does what
city Folk don't have the stomach to do
you didn't kill her I I sang her her
favorite songs
it was beautiful and gentle and
respectful I fed her antihistamines and
she gradually fell asleep well then she
barf them up in the freezer and tried to
get out well I'm not responsible for
that Hey ow
it's okay nothing I'm robbing her it's
nothing it's fine what
do that without telling me I thought I
was helping you I expected a hug I took
care of that cat the best way I knew how
Heaven is a beautiful place but you
don't get there if you're euthanized
what do we do use this surge of fear and
adrenaline to sharpen your
decision-making okay I am not dying here
come on
oh
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
this has been a test of our emergency
preparedness there is no fire it was
only a simulation what for five years
I've held my instincts in check because
I wanted to be made manager
maybe it's time for me to just let that
thought go
it's kind of painful but it's also
freeing in a way
now it's all about my instincts
hey Dwight Stanley
one way or another you are going to come
with me to make this sale
can you just let me out of here before
whatever comes next don't worry it's
just a bull tranquilizer nothing to be
alarmed about it's just a man pointing a
bull tranquilizer at a co-worker Dwight
you do not learn do you for threat to be
credible
no you didn't I'm sick of you
foreign
Andy approved it right
being here with you and the German
Mennonite minister
felt right
I know you did
and that's why I have taken care of
everything what do you mean my monkey
he's a real Minister and you said I do
and I said I do and Andy wasn't signing
a receipt he was signing our marriage
certificate as a witness
Dwight that doesn't count yes of course
it does no
it does in the state of Pennsylvania
shrut we are not married what
not my fault you don't understand German
I've been telling you to take
it to take are we uh
we leaving or what
I am attacking myself with a throat
punch here it comes block grasp wrist as
such and what if it comes at you with
the other hand because he does have two
good point second throat punch
absorb the blow
groin punch hit block elbow to the gut
uh oh up to the nose no you're not ah oh
my God
he's making you look like such a fool he
really is but not for long
I can't hold on you two are so evenly
mashed I don't know how one of you is
going to get the upper hand the
important thing to remember Jim we
always have what is called the element
of surprise
ah
hey helper
hey
right right
[Music]
Pam please call security
every day for eight years I have brought
pepper spray into this office to protect
myself and my fellow employees
every day for eight years people have
laughed at me well Who's Laughing Now
Dwight and I have implemented a new
program that we like to call
right the accountability booster it
registers every time a mistake has been
made in the office from a late delivery
to an accounting error five strikes in a
day equals a home run one home run and
you're out
if we as a group make five mistakes in a
day something bad happens like we block
Minesweeper or in this case an email
gets sent to Robert California
containing the Consultants report from
last year remember the one that
recommended the branch be shut down and
as a Fail-Safe also every negative email
you've ever written about him to the
group will also be forwarded to him what
emails are you talking about Robert's
favorite songs Creep by TLC Creep by
Radiohead remember that one Jim
uh there's no way he hasn't strangled at
least one stripper Oscar
he eats his yogurt like he is punishing
it for disappointing him Kelly
actually P.S we should kill him
wait so you installed the doomsday
device no it's an accountability booster
which when it goes off it destroys
everything very similar to a doomsday
device Jim you're trying to make me
sound like some kind of evil Maniac now
the point is is that we are now working
in an environment where we have
accountability to each other I am
confident that you guys are equal to the
task
um no we're not and you are a psycho who
is ruining our lives
Merry Christmas
no why why did you bring that here don't
worry she's dead oh wait
he's dead why what
I accidentally ran over it it's a
Christmas miracle well get it out of
here relax okay and because this is
Christmas I am going to roast this goose
and prepare it with a wild rice dressing
do we have any cayenne pepper in the
kitchen
Christmas tonight Jim wow I'm out of
here what
End Circle gets the square right
so can you watch this I'm gonna get my
carving knife out of the trunk do I have
any thoughts about this no Toby this is
different he's already dead
once I brought in a dock to prepare for
lunch
and people got upset
apparently they got attached to the duck
and didn't want to see it killed he was
already dead and we shrutes use every
part of the goose the meat has a
delicious Smoky rich flavor plus you can
use the molten goose grease and save it
in the refrigerator thus saving you a
trip to the store for a can of expensive
goose grease wow win-win